so as we know the russians are in a
number of positions around ukraine just
tell us where we are on day eight
yes kamali i mean day eight um
it's it's a two-front war there is a
northern front where the russians are
trying to surround kiev and move in to
actually remove the government and a
southern front where they're going for
territory uh and eventually those
northern and southern fronts they would
hope uh will actually link up they're
surrounding cities now that's the stage
route so chunahiv sumi
are all surrounded as are the big cities
in the south yes it's a fight for the
city of the north but you mentioned the
cities in the south and as we know in
the past day or so uh the city of
kerason in the south has as we
understand it fallen to the russians
just explain to us the importance of
these cities we can see odessa there
question mario paul these cities for the
ukrainians yeah three big cities out
mario paul should have fallen within
hours of the assault beginning day eight
uh there's no water no electricity
they're still hanging on i don't know
how they're doing it but they are uh
surrounded kirschen uh taken and
surrounded uh there is still some fight
incursion and odessa increasingly looks
as if it is going to be surrounded and
odessa of course is the port uh taking
odessa which i'm sure the russians will
try to do will be economically
disastrous for ukraine yeah and we have
seen some footage coming out from the
last couple of hours that shows some
ships off the coast of crimea now what
do they tell us about what may well be
happening next well there's more than 30
odd uh major battleships russian
battleships in the black sea at least
seven of them are missile carrying ships
three submarines but among that group
there are six assault ships five
standard ones one very big one those
assault ships normally carry about 12
tanks maybe 36 armored personnel
carriers and they carry about 300 troops
so five or six of those is quite a punch
to actually deliver if they're all going
to be used together in preparation for
an amphibious assault one would assume a
an amphibious assault on odessa is
probably the next step okay michael
clark thank you very much